[Musica]
autofocus realtà sfocata o per essere
più precisi ancora un disallineamento
tra le condizioni reali in cui si trova
il nostro paese e la percezione che se
ne ha l'umore che si raccoglie
noi non siamo mai stati in italia così
ricchi
così sani
e così longevi quanto siamo adesso però
se vi guardate attorno se parlate con le
persone con le quali convivete e
condividete le vostre esperienze insomma
l'umore non è tra i migliori dice che il
malumore siamo si diffonde come mai
questo è possibile ecco cercheremo di
vedere alcuni sintomi alcuni analisti
come fossero analisi cliniche del perché
questo è potuto succedere
la prima cosa naturalmente e da parte
della ricchezza noi abbiamo un debito
pubblico è esagerato pesantissimo 2.400
miliardi
a fronte di questi 2.400 miliardi di
debito pubblico però abbiamo un
patrimonio delle famiglie che non
raggiunge ma insomma viaggia verso i
10mila miliardi poco più della metà e in
in beni immobili un poco meno della metà
e in beni mobili cioè in investimenti
finanziari 1.300 miliardi sono liquidi
in questo momento sui conti correnti nel
all'inizio degli anni 70
l'italia aveva un patrimonio medio delle
famiglie quindi medico cioè quello che
c'era il castello è quello che non ci
aveva mai con un tetto sulla testa ma un
patrimonio medio delle famiglie pari
all'epoca a due volte
il il re di tre volte il reddito annuo
attualmente
in germania esattamente come in germania
attualmente in germania hanno un reddito
pari a sei volte un re un patrimonio
pari a sei volte il reddito annuo
noi abbiamo raggiunto nove volte
reddituale cioè i ricchi
patrimonialmente parlando siamo noi
io credo che questo siamo se provate a
dirlo in giro la percezione è
normalmente è pressoché opposta
il nostro debito pubblico però è molto
alto 2.400 miliardi mi hanno detto prima
nel 1995 era più basso aveva un peso sul
percentuale sul prodotto interno lordo
pari al 120 per cento e pagavamo però la
bellezza del 9,5 per cento di interessi
9,5 per cento del prodotto interno lordo
oggi abbiamo un debito più alto di
quanto non l'avessimo nel 95 ma abbiamo
pa paghiamo di interessi il 3,5 per
cento del nostro prodotto interno lordo
questo chiarisce le idee che la speranza
di solo l'illusione di risolvere il
problema del nostro debito pubblico
tornando indietro quello che si chiama
con un grande illusione la sovranità
monetaria essere proprietari della
proprio manipolo siamo anche adesso la
condividiamo con altri paesi europei ma
lo siamo in cadetto
in ogni caso prima pagavamo un'infinità
di più cioè ci costava molto di più non
è un buon affare per molti
il mondo e la storia sembrano cominciare
nel 1200 mila e 13 2014 e continuano a
dire ma l'italia ha un deficit che è non
solo nella media degli altri paesi
europei ma è meno degli altri paesi
europei di deficit
se però il mondo non è cominciato in
quell'anno lì il mondo è cominciato
prima di questo grafico che guarda che
vedete la linea blu e il deficit cioè la
spesa maggiore rispetto alle entrate che
l'italia ha fatto negli anni e purtroppo
come vedete la linea blu e
abbondantemente più in basso abbiamo
fatto una marea di deficit e in passato
e questo ha creato una conseguenza che è
il debito pubblico
i debiti sono tutti abbastanza elevati
ma anche qui la linea blu è quella
italiana e quella che trovate in alto è
il debito più alto se il debito se fare
deficit per fare debito portasse
ricchezza l'italia dovrebbe essere il
paese più ricco e che cresce più
velocemente europa purtroppo non è così
siamo inchiodati a non crescere sono
anni che facciamo la metà quando va bene
della crescita della media dell'unione
europea e dell'unione monetaria europea
e quando si recede quando si va indietro
andiamo indietro molto più velocemente
rispetto agli altri questo grafico fa
vedere quale è stata l'andamento della
nostra creazione di ricchezza l'italia
come vedete a una crescita quando
ammesso che si possa chiamare crescita
perché prima parte degli anni in una
decrescita decisamente inferiore
rispetto a quella degli altri
questo ha un è uno dei riflessi della
produttività noi abbiamo una
produttività molto bassa però ignora che
lavoriamo
portiamo a casa meno prodotto va
aggiunto meno valore aggiunto di quello
che accade in altri paesi europei
questo dato viene molto spesso
equivocato perché sembra quasi che sia
diciamo un giudizio sulla capacità dei
lavoratori italiani non è così
intanto perché i lavoratori italiani
sono meno di quello che sono altrove
noi abbiamo una parte ci poniamo ogni
mese litighiamo a non finire sul tasso
di disoccupazione e di aumentato è
diminuito le ore lavorate le persone
occupate tutto molto interessante però
il dato fondamentale è un altro non è il
numero di disoccupati è il numero di
occupati cioè il rispetto alla
popolazione che può lavorare quanti in
italia lavorano troppo pochi questo
naturalmente crea un problema di
produttività ma soprattutto
noi abbiamo un deficit mostruoso nel
mondo dell'istruzione
non solo questo diciamo così è la
raffigurazione grafica del numero di
persone sulla popolazione sulla
percentuale di popolazione che ha una
qualifica è un titolo di studio
superiore terziario ma al di là del
titolo di studio perché i titoli
lasciano il tempo che trovano
se la deve vedere i risultati dei test
invalsi dei test pisa sono drammatici
cioè si arriva alla maturità
in condizioni
che siamo sopra il 30 per cento
dell'analfabetismo funzionale cioè nel
leggere e comprendere un testo complesso
si supera il 40 per cento
quando si passa a dover far di conto
cioè sui numeri
e queste percentuali che sono le
percentuali nazionali diventano
drammatiche nel sud italia dove si
supera regolarmente il 50 per cento cioè
dove l'istruzione dovrebbe funzionare di
più per cercare di riequilibrare far
ripartire la crescita anche civile e
culturale morale di un paese in realtà
funziona meno l'istruzione è un elemento
di produttività un mondo del lavoro ed i
lavoratori che sanno meno producono meno
perché non siamo mica nell'era
dell'economia della zappa in cui quello
che conta è la muscolatura e questa è la
giustizia fa potremmo andare avanti per
tanti altri la burocrazia ci fermiamo
qua questa è la giustizia
se tu hai un mercato nel quale la
giustizia funziona poco diventa un
mercato inaffidabile un mercato
inaffidabile o un mercato poco
produttivo perché perdo troppo tempo
perdo troppo tempo a cercare di far
rispettare le norme per cercare di far
rispettare un contratto a cercare dio
scooter è una garanzia
la giustizia che non funziona è un
pazzesco incidente e ostacolo alla
crescita di un paese
noi però parliamo di scuola parliamo di
giustizia solo e soltanto per parlare
della condizione dei magistrati e degli
avvocati dei precari degli insegnanti
dei bidelli dei medici e paramedici
nella sanità cioè come se in servizio al
cittadino che significa curare istruire
rendere giustizia fosse un optional di
questi settori
questo si riflette nella capacità di un
paese di crescere
oltre a essere ricchi ma con quei
problemi siamo longevi e questo mi pare
un fatto positivo diciamo specialmente
per quelli che hanno superato una certà
età sapere di avere un po più di tempo
un fatto positivo
siamo tra i più longevi in in europa e
che significa che siamo tra i più
longevi nel mondo e ci arriviamo anche
in buone condizioni di salute ogni tanto
ci sono i giornali che pubblica notizie
di sai sono in aumento le cardiopatie in
italia che non si preoccupa pure spoglia
domanda come è possibile che è successo
è successo che invecchiamo cioè è chiaro
che se non schiatti a 50 60 anni
nell'andare avanti del tempo la tua
patologie potrebbero crescere ed è
normale che sia così siamo più longevi
ma facciamo molti meno figli
questa è la condizione dell'andamento la
curva in basso sono nel tempo gli
italiani con meno di 5 anni
la curva che va verso l'alto sono nel
tempo gli italiani compiuti 65 anni
quella che va verso l'alto va benissimo
è molto bella è quella che va verso il
basso un po meno
ora se noi qui la per il disallineamento
fuori fuoco rispetto alla realtà se
domandiamo in giro perché non si fanno
figli guardate che la risposta che
raccogliete sarà sempre la stessa non
c'è la sicurezza del futuro non c'è un
posto fisso tempo pieno e con un
contratto a tempo indeterminato
la banca non dà il mutuo per la casa
ormai le banche sono diventata in questa
favola anche degli anticoncezionali cosa
che non era prevedibile
nell'immediato passato ed è talmente è
talmente questo applauso alle banche che
si rendono utili facendo degli
anticoncezionali e è talmente evidente
talmente scontata questa risposta che
non viene neanche messa in dubbio
solo che poi tu ci pensi
vai a guardare
le tabelle statistiche ti accorgi che
noi avevamo una natalità superiore nel
1943 che nel 1943 c'era più sicurezza
del lavoro
più sicurezza del futuro
la banca ti dà venuto al è già un
miracolo se ritrovavi la casa c'erano i
bombardamenti non era
e allora cosa è successo vai a guardare
gli altri numeri sapete quanto spendiamo
noi ogni anno
per la prima infanzia in italia si
spendono 835 milioni di euro
sapete quanto spendiamo per gli animali
domestici
2 miliardi e 600 milioni di euro ma che
ci stiamo raccontando noi ci stiamo
raccontando la favola che uno non mette
al mondo un figlio perché non sa se
riuscirà a dargli da mangiare e quindi
compra un labrador che da solo mangia
ogni giorno una settimana di nutrimento
del suddetto figlio con la giunta
peraltro che il figlio prima o poi il
bambino impara a farla nel vasino
e poi direttamente in bagno il labrador
no continua a far tra lì davanti per
tutta la vita
questa questione della natalità non è un
una predica un predicozzo da parroco
della serie la messa è finita andate e
moltiplicatevi è un problema serio nel
senso che questo è l'andamento delle
persone
in età da lavoro cioè tra i 20 e 64 anni
la parte in alto quella rossa e l'unione
europea
la media europea che va male perché con
questo andamento alle persone in età da
lavoro che possono lavare diminuiscono
progressivamente lui europea ma l'italia
alla linea blu cioè decisamente peggio
in queste condizioni noi finiamo per
giunta aggiungiamo che siamo quelli dove
si lavora meno
tra i 55 64 anni poi non sentiamo
parlare altro in questo paese che di
pensionati il problema dei penso
agevolare le persone che devono andare
in pensione
i contributi che sono stati versati da
ciascun lavoratori sono proprietà del
lavoratore stesso
il problema delle agevolazioni è che la
gran parte delle pensioni in pagamento
sono finanziate in parte da contributi
di altri lavoratori e della fiscalità
generale cioè dal contribuente non sono
sostenuti dai dai versamenti fatti nel
corso dell'età lavorativa
questo significa che tu non solo ai meno
gente in prospettiva che lavora non solo
ai un numero di anziani che è destinato
a crescere ma già oggi hai un numero di
persone che lavorano
in età e non è anziana tra i 55 64 anni
che è largamente inferiore a quello di
altri paesi europei e ti lamenti del
fatto che si lavora troppo a lungo in
italia cioè ci stiamo raccontando delle
favole altamente nocive
questo è il problema crea un innesca una
questione e cioè noi siamo il paese
l'italia è il paese con la più alta
percentuale di pensionati sui lavoratori
in questo andamento anzi oserei dire con
questo andazzo nel 2050 avremo 105
pensionati ogni 100 lavoratori ora non è
questione che uno sia di destra di
sinistra liberista socialista è che
semplicemente non regge così non sta in
piedi
questo sono diciamo l'altro tema alcune
italia se angoscia gli immigrati gli
immigrati sono troppi gli immigrati
questi sono i non nativi nella media
degli altri paesi europei l'italia è
decisamente in basso questo non
significa che devono entrare più
immigrati o che vogliamoci bene
significa semplicemente
che l'approccio al tema
dell'immigrazione tutto sentimentale
tutto con il cuore in mano che sia per
volersi bene o per volersi male che sia
per abbracciarsi anziché per respingersi
serve a niente serve assolutamente a
niente tanto è vero che il governo forse
più determinato nel bloccare le chiude
riporti le frontiere cioè il conte uno
nei conti del documento di economia e
finanza scriveva esplicitamente che
abbiamo bisogno di 165 mila immigrati in
più ogni anno tutti gli anni perché è
per i conti che vi ho fatto vedere prima
se no chi li paga le pensioni degli
altri chi paga lo stato sociale degli
altri non sono d'accordo con questa
impostazione ma non c'è dubbio che se tu
mantieni ferme le premesse poi non
riesce più a controllare le conseguenze
ho concluso qual è il il problema
serissimo del disallineamento problema
serissimo al disallineamento è che un
paese che è ricco
un paese che la seconda potenza
industriale d'europa le nostre
esportazioni non hanno mai smesso di
crescere quindi un paese che ha una
struttura produttiva forte capace di
reagire
continua ad auto in lo ad
autoalimentarsi di oppiacei cercando di
fare in modo da spiegare a se stesso che
la realtà è diversa da quello che è che
il problema non è quello di andare a
lavorare di fare qualcosa di prepararsi
di studiare di ricercare di innovare per
mantenere le posizioni di forza che
abbiamo mai quello di accaparrarsi
qualche rendita prima che il debito
pubblico si mangi tutto anche il
patrimonio dei privati questa illusione
questo fraintendimento questo sfocamento
della realtà porta male ed è la ragione
per la quale a partire dal sud italia il
problema serio bisognerebbe gridarlo al
mondo non è quello di essere assistiti è
quello di essere liberati dall
assistenza e messi nelle condizioni di
fare quello che la dignità
la moralità
e l'orgoglio di ciascuno di noi prevede
e impone essere protagonisti della
nostra vita e sapersela guadagnare con
il nostro lavoro
vi ringrazio grazie